nom de code 90 60 90 voici l'histoire
d'Ana Chapman l'espionne russe surnommé
la nouvelle Matahari un épisode digne de
la guerre froide Poutine il trouve dans
Anna Chapman son équivalent en jupons
nous sommes en 2010 le président
américain Barack Obama reçoit son
homologue russe Dimitri Medvedev sur
fond de réchauffement diplomatique entre
les deux grandes puissances
mais alors que les deux présidents
célèbres leur rapprochement le FBI est
sur le point d'arrêter une dizaine
d'espions russes sur le sol américain
des agents Normands dissimulés sous de
fausses identités c'est l'opération
ghostories
c'était des gens qui avaient endossé des
fausses identités de personnes décédées
pour certains d'enfants de bébés morts
donc on parlait de fantômes ces agents
parfois en couple avec enfants mener la
vie d'américain tranquille pour certains
depuis les années 90 leur objectif se
fondre dans la masse pour infiltrer les
cercles politiques et récolter des
informations sensibles sur les
États-Unis c'est complètement
rocambolesque on n'imaginait pas un seul
instant aux États-Unis que il y a ces
familles en fait de d'agents dormants
infiltrés depuis des années sur ces
images déclassifiées par le FBI on voit
les agents russes récupérer ou échanger
des documents et même enterré de
l'argent parmi les agents ciblées par le
FBI on retrouve Ana Chapman une business
woman à la tête d'une agence immobilière
destinée aux clients fortunés russes
c'est quelqu'un de très intelligent
c'est quelqu'un qui avait de l'ambition
et la presse américaine s'emballe pour
cette espionne russe elle a tout de
suite une grande popularité échappement
la presse a eu connaissance de cette
affaire parce que effectivement il
correspondait parfaitement à ce
stéréotype à ce cliché de la femme
fatale russe venue du froid c'est du
Christ rousse on l'appelait l'agent 90
60-90 ses mensurations voilà on fait le
tour du monde l'ex-mari d'un échappement
dévoile au journal ce télégraphe des
photos sexy de son ex-compagne et des
détails sur leur vie sexuelle
dès ce point
un échappement est né en Russie au début
des années 80 sous le nom d'Anna
kuchenko son père est un ancien cadre du
KGB l'ancêtre des services secrets
russes à 20 ans à peine elle épouse Alex
Chapman le fils d'un homme d'affaire
britannique qu'elle a rencontré quelques
mois plus tôt ensemble il quitte Moscou
pour s'installer à Londres
ça devient un peu la capitale des Russes
expatriés du russe expatriés pour des
raisons politiques comme par exemple
Boris des rizowski l'ancien oligarque la
bête noire de Vladimir Poutine et des
gens expatriés pour des raisons
économiques qui s'achètent des biens
immobiliers pour des millions de livres
on parle de Londres à ce moment-là Anna
commence à fréquenter la diaspora russe
et les hautes sphères de la société
londonienne la relation entre les jeunes
mariés se détériorent rapidement
[Musique]
on pense que à ce moment là puschenko
Chapman travaille déjà pour le SFR pour
le renseignement extérieur russe et que
sa mission en fait c'est de surveiller
justement cette émigration et notamment
l'immigration politique et que va faire
à Chatman elle va tout faire pour
rencontrer des réseaux skis pour le
séduire alors on sait pas s'ils ont été
vraiment amants on sait qu'ils sont vus
à de très nombreuses reprises qu'ils ont
eu de très longue discussion et tout ce
qui lui a raconté ce qui lui a dit sur
Poutine sur ses projets bien sûr ça a
été rapporté ruiner et dépressif Boris
berizowski est retrouvé pendu en 2013
dans la salle de bain de sa maison du
Berkshire au Royaume-Uni au milieu des
années 2000 le couple Chapman divorce
Anna retourne quelques temps à Moscou
avant de s'envoler pour New York avec un
nouvel objectif faire des affaires dans
l'immobilier
ce talent à se faire des amis à séduire
le flirt etc ce qui est impressionnant
c'est sa capacité à obtenir les numéros
de téléphone des gens il y a un témoin
qui a raconté qu'il faut aller dans une
église en Angleterre qui est la même
obtenue le numéro de téléphone d'un
prêtre Anna Chapman voit les choses en
grand elle habite le twenty eXtense
place un prestigieux gratte-ciel en
plein coeur du quartier des affaires de
Manhattan son entreprise compte
rapidement 50 employés elle est
surveillée étroitement par la FBI qui
découvre assez vite que une fois par
mois tous les mercredis elle rencontre
quelqu'un elle se poste à un Starbucks
par exemple avec un ordinateur avec un
portable le type se trouve dans une
camionnette un peu plus loin et les deux
ordinateurs se connectent
automatiquement via un réseau wifi privé
sur ces vidéos de surveillance on voit
Anna Chapman s'entretenir avec un
certain romane un espion russe qui en
fait est un agent du FBI
celui-ci lui confie une mission délivrée
des documents à une autre espionne russe
au début elle se méfie puis elle le
croit puis elle va avoir un nouveau des
doutes un Chapman finit par montrer son
ordinateur au faux agent russe afin
qu'il le répare c'est quand même une
erreur d'amateur faut le dire et le fait
de montrer un ordinateur à quelqu'un
qu'on est censé ne pas connaître
évidemment c'est avouer finalement sa
culpabilité d'une certaine manière après
l'autre vue avec le faux agent russe
Anna Chapman appelle son père qui lui
conseille de se rendre au poste de
police pour montrer patte blanche il y a
deux agents du FBI qui sont là qui se
font passer pour des policiers qui
l'accueillent qui lui disent ah et bien
écoutez on va vous montrer des photos
vous allez nous dire si la personne qui
vous a contacté ressemble à ces gens-là
et ils vont faire durer durer durée
durée durée parce qu'à ce moment là vous
avez aux États-Unis Dimitri medvedef le
président de la Fédération de Russie qui
effectue un séjour entre guillemets
historique
le président russe profite de son voyage
aux États-Unis pour se rendre en
Californie où il rencontre le fondateur
d'Apple Steve Jobs il rencontre même
Schwarzenegger quand il est à Hollywood
on veut surtout pas que l'arrestation de
Chapman et les autres illégaux se
produisent au moment où mes VDF est
encore sur le sol américain donc on
attend que l'avion de Metz a décollé
pour arrêter de Chapman et les autres
illégaux
10 espions sont arrêtés dans le cadre de
l'opération Ghost Stories certains
d'entre eux risquent jusqu'à 25 ans de
prison et sur la scène internationale
une image que l'on pensait ne plus
jamais voir celle d'un gigantesque
échange d'espion un épisode digne de la
guerre froide quelques jours plus tard
les illégaux sont échangés contre des
prisonniers russes sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport de Vienne en Autriche il
fallait à tout prix éviter le scandale
c'est fait pour ne pas gâcher la bonne
entente retrouver entre les présidents
un rapprochement scellé par un accord
sur le désarmement nucléaire il y a tout
juste deux mois
parmi les espions échangés sergueïs
grippal un ancien officier des
renseignements russes ayant collaboré
avec les Américains c'est un échange un
peu inégal évidemment ce clipal il a
fait beaucoup plus de mal à la Russie
que Anna Chapman a fait du mal aux
États-Unis c'est incomparable
huit ans plus tard Serge creepal et sa
fille sont victimes d'un empoisonnement
au novicq sur un banc public en
Angleterre ils ont réchapperont
inextremis le FBI n'aurait jamais pu
arrêter les illégaux russes aux
États-Unis sans l'aide d'une taupe
d'un agent infiltré au sein du SVR du
service de renseignement extérieur russe
l'homme qui a collaboré avec les
Américains c'est lui Alexandre potée
responsable du service des illégaux et
agents double depuis la fin des années
90 donc ce potage informe le FBI sur les
faits et gestes des illégaux qui se
trouvent alors aux États-Unis et sur le
travail d'un Chatman lors de leur retour
en Russie les illégaux ont le droit à un
accueil triomphale il rencontre Vladimir
Poutine qui profite de l'occasion pour
faire passer un message
de son côté Ana Chapman se déshabille en
une du magazine Maxime et CC à une
carrière dans le
mannequinataire
du Kremlin quelques mois après son
retour forcé elle est invitée au Congrès
des jeunesse de Russie Unie le parti
présidentiel
en 2014 elle apparaît dans un programme
TV pour faire la promotion de l'armée
russe et glorifie l'invasion du Dombas
et l'annexion de la Crimée aujourd'hui
Anna Chapman anime chaque semaine une
émission à la télévision russe les
secrets du monde avec Anna Chapman où
elle aborde les phénomènes les plus
mystérieux du monde moderne